hello everyone and welcome to a really
enjoyable game uh from the 1960 martial
model plata tournament that was played
in argentina uh it's boris posky versus
robert james fisher or or bobby fischer
yeah it is their first encounter and
interestingly uh boris posky uh arrived
to martial plata with david bronstein
they were
the only two russian players or the only
two soviets that arrived for the
tournament as the other the other guys
were pretty busy uh tal just won his
world church championship match against
uh botwinnik and uh well
everyone's been doing their thing uh but
here uh uh spots esparza and breinstein
uh arrived and spassky was around 23
years old bobby was 17 here and when
they were arriving um uh you can see
that today the quote above the board
from david bronstein's book says that
they did not even know that bobby was
participating in the tournament and even
though spassky never met bobby bronstein
did
get to know bobby because they played
that together in the porto rojin trisono
in 1958 two years ago you know the the
one that uh got him invited in the uh
greatest candidate tournament uh of all
times the 1959 candidates tournament
and fisher even um uh finished half a
point uh half point ahead of david
braunstein so it's a really fun game uh
you guys will enjoy it uh so let's check
it out and uh let's all wish uh spasky a
great 85th birthday and many more to
come so spasky with the white pieces
opens with ponte e4 and yeah of course
uh interestingly when
uh bronstein and spassky arrived bobby
was away waving at them from the train
uh and bernstein uh immediately uh
recognized bobby and he introduced him
to spassky and that's basically how how
the two of them got
got to know know each other and they've
been on really good terms uh ever since
so here spassky opens with e4 we have e5
by fischer and now f4 uh sparsky goes
for for the king's gambit and bobby
happily accepts this with e captures on
f4
knight to f3 and now comes g5 so like in
the old days uh the theory still stands
uh much like uh
when anderson and morphy played it uh we
have h4 and now g4 grabbing more space
chasing away the knight knight to e5 and
knight to f6 so everything the same like
in
the days of anderson and morphy
and now there are three main replies
here uh for white after knight to f6 you
could play bishop to c4 you could play
d4 or you could play knight captures on
g4 and they're all very very interesting
so we're just gonna show a couple of
them for example if knight captures on
g4 knight captures an e4 is very nice
going after the g3 square now we chase
away the knight knight g3 and the bishop
captures an f4 and now it's interesting
that the rook cannot be captured if uh
or better yet queen e7 check first and
then after bishop to e2 uh the rook can
now not be captured if the rook is
captured the bishop f6 and now black
just gets destroyed so what you would
have to do is just continue the game
let's say rook g8 you go after the
knight and now after the knight is
captured we're going to capture the
knight on g4 in the game continues with
a really really sharp game for both
sides so that's one of the options uh
like i said knight g4 the other very
interesting one is bishop to c4 going
after the f7 square right away uh so d5
is pretty much forced and after e
captures on d5 we just block the pawn
with bishop to d6 and this is perfectly
fine
for example d4 in both players castle
castles castles and the game continues
you can see that it's incredibly sharp
but uh well
that is what you're looking for if you
play the king's gambit but okay after
knight to f6 spawsky goes for d for the
third line that we are now going to
show we have d6 chasing away the knight
and the knight to d3 as now the bishop
guards the g4 pawn as well so knights to
d3 and here bobby captures on e4 we have
knight captures on e4 now knights the g3
check could be very annoying so bishop
captures an f4 removing the defender of
the g3 square and now bishop to g7
attacking the d4 pawn and while you
could defend it with a move like pawn to
c3 that means you will have trouble
developing your knight so spassky just
plays knight to c3s he says okay your
knight on e4 is undefended uh do
something about that or if you capture
on c3 then i'm going to play b captures
in c3 and my d4 pawn will be defended so
this is what fischer plays knight
captures on c3 we have b captures on c3
and now bobby strikes in the center with
c5 and this is all very very good stuff
you can see that bobby did quite a lot
of work um even on the king's gambit
there's black even though he's only 17
here
and now comes the bishop to e2 putting
more pressure on the g4 pawn and it's
also as of movie 11 that this position
has never been reached again so now it's
a unique game and now bobby has to
decide does he capture on d4 or does he
castle first and then capture on d4
because you want to capture on d4 it's
just a
free pawn so he does it the c captures
on d4 but now esposky just castles and
now capturing on c3 would be a little
bit too dangerous if he grabs another
pawn then we play bishop captures on g4
and now you have this if bishop captures
queen captures you have a lot of
pressure on g7 so you'd probably castle
but then for example captures captures
and you pick up the d6 pawn you attack
the rook and if rook d8 even bishop e7
uh attacks the real rook d7 bishop f6
you you can trade the the bishop here
and this bishop is a
pretty important defender of the king
side so black would not enjoy defending
this so instead just knight to c6
fischer has to continue developing
pieces and now we have bishop captures
on g4 uh bobby castles and now bishop
captures in c8 rook captures in c8 so
you keep an eye on the d6 spawn and now
queen to g4 putting pressure on the g
file and now bishop to h6 would be very
very good if if spawsky can play this
then the game ends on the spot so bobby
plays f5 he chases away the queen also
now all of the pieces can help out with
the defense of the seventh rank uh queen
to g3 with a double attack on the d6
pawn and now bobby just captures on c3
so what do you play here well spasky
just continues developing rook 8 to e1
playing this in great style like the old
masters would we have king h8 bobby and
pins the king from the g file and now
prepares rook to g8 to put some pressure
on white's king king's side so king h1
you could go after the pawn first but uh
bishop rook jason bishop to d4 are moves
that will probably happen so it makes
sense to move the king away to a light
square and now rook the g8 threatening
some nasty discoveries but just bishop
captures and these spassky says you have
no nasty discoveries you can try
whatever you want so here bobby plays
bishop to f8 and this is in fact all all
best moves so both of them are pretty
much playing the uh the best moves
spassky playing some
well maybe not all the top moves but
fischer playing pretty much all the top
moves
and now uh black is lost unless he plays
bishop to e5 check this is a move you
have to play uh because your bishop is
hanging your queen is saying so bishop
e5 is a must so here bishop to e5 check
bobby captures the bishop we have queen
captures on e5 and now rook to g7 you
could also play bishop to g7 but bobby
wants the rook to control the g file uh
so he blocks with the rook we have rook
captures on f5 now uh and the queen
captures an h4 with check king to g1 and
now queen to g4 uh you don't have bishop
to c5 check because that square is
sufficiently defended by spawsky's
pieces so queen g4 now fischer is
threatening checkmate with queen
captures on g2 and spawsky moves the
rook back rook f2
defending the
uh the g2 pawn and now it's uh
well it's it's a really a remarkable
position where uh even though it seems
like you have something you really don't
uh
this position has to be played very very
precisely you have to play some like b6
or offer a queen trade with queen g5 or
keep attacking but without uh allowing
your position to deteriorate so here uh
fischer continues attacking he plays
bishop to e7 he wants bishop to h4 to go
after the rooks
and now rook to e for attacking the
queen
basically saying that if you play queen
to d1 uh then it's uh it's just a draw
uh but luckily for spawsky fischer was
not interested in the draw against
possibly for example queen d1 check rook
f1 we're gonna play queen captures on c2
and now rook g4 and the rook cannot move
so how do you defend well rook to g8 and
now we would see a trait captures
captures and queen b8 check and now you
will have a repetition via this triangle
here uh rogue jade queen to e5 check
rook g7 queen to g8 check rook g7 and so
on queen to e5 check will be a a draw by
three four repetition or a perpetual or
what not so here queen to g5 was played
now bobby offers a queen trade because
he is up upon if the queens get traded
that would be uh well
that would be good for him and plus not
only is he up upon he has a bishop
against tonight would play on both sides
of the board he would he would he would
be better here so after queen to g5 we
have queen to d4 spawsky has to keep
chances alive he has to keep the
material on the board uh and now fischer
has to find the move and again he can
play b6 something like b five he can
play rook rook city g8 that's also a
move but he goes for the kill he plays
rook to f8 and that will simply not do
he wants to remove one of the defenders
of the g2 square
but now the position is completely
winning for spassky but it's very
interesting how it happens so feel free
to pause the video and win this game for
for spassky while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on on spotting this
uh well brilliant brilliant uh uh
maneuver and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is rook to e5
and all of a sudden you realize that the
queen cannot keep defending the bishop
the queen covers h4 the rook covers the
f6 square so you really don't have a
square for the queen to keep an eye on
the bishop on e7 so if you play queen g4
we're just gonna trade captures captures
and we pick up the bishop we're up a
piece so bobby tries the only thing
that's left
and that is to go after spawsky's queen
with rook to d8 now he says all right
you capture my queen i'm going to
capture your queen but now spawsky plays
queen to e4 and the queen is still
hanging and the bishop is attacked twice
by the rook and by the queen so bobby
plays the only thing that's left queen
to h4 now says all right my bishop is
sufficiently defended uh and uh we are
now again uh
in this uh uh position where a queen
trade is offered but uh rook to f4 by
spassky and it is now in this position
on move 29 that bobby fischer resigned
the game as there is nothing to be done
uh all of the squares have been taken
from the black queen you have to move
the queen somewhere and after we move
the queen we're just gonna gobble up the
the bishop and that's it bobby's down a
piece and of course he resigns here so
this is just uh incredible and you might
think okay well of course spasky won
this is a 17 year old fisher uh who okay
he he qualified for for the candidates
tournament last year but still it's a 17
year old bobby fischer but if you look
at the actual standings uh after the
tournament and uh let me just check i
don't know if i prepare them yeah i
didn't give me give me a few seconds
i will prepare them uh and also yeah
while we're here let me just show you
guys this uh
this is a nice one uh it's uh from the
website of friedrich olafsson uh
these are the the participants of the of
the 1960 model plata tournament so you
guys can enjoy this uh while i'm uh
preparing the standings let me just
enlarge this a little bit for you you
can see and also try and try and see how
many uh players can you spot of course
you can see fisher and spassky there in
the front row sitting you can see fisher
with the biggest smile ever on his face
and spassky not all that impressed uh
that is being here that's braunstein
next uh next to fisher that's all of so
next spassky so try and figure out how
many of these players you know while i
while i prepare the standings
[Music]
[Music]
all right so the standings have been
prepared
uh let's just enjoy that for a little
bit more there we go now now let's check
out the standings
uh here they are uh now these are the
standings of the 1960 model plata
tournament uh look at this uh spassky uh
13 and a half out of 15 fisher 13 and a
half out of 15. so it doesn't really
matter that fisher was 17
he completely crashed the tournament and
if it weren't for this loss against
spassky then it would be a
a a very one-sided event uh this way was
called the two horse race but as you can
see uh both spassky and fischer are full
two points ahead of david braunstein and
uh interestingly uh bobby fischer only
lost the spassky this game and he drew
uh his game to braunschweig so this is
his second draw um
against braunschwein and he then won 13
games
altogether so he has more wins than
spawsky but he had a loss against
possibly so uh they shared first place
in those days there you didn't have tie
breaks
they just had a shared first place so
you can see uh how uh
how strong bobby was here but still
spawsky completely demolished them in
this king's gambit in the first game
they ever played uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it uh
very happy that uh spassky is doing well
uh i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to franco tonello and i would
like to thank me for the best chess
videos andre theron and nagarjuna
pongotti and the gm sucks rocks for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon i continue to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and always
play the king's gambit